I am obsessed there's a moment in  bloodsport that's iconic and you know  what I'm talking about the crotch punch  the crotch punch is one of the most  iconic moments let's take a look  [Music]  is that is that something I could use in  real life or is that just for movies all  right was cinematic the idea came under  said since I was very flexible what  about if I go on a split position and I  go inside the you know the legs  but you know what in in fighting combat  I mean I know they have rules and  descenders and techniques but if you if  you're very aware of your body and your  capability like East all you are stocky  you know more thin so we have to think  how we can protect ourselves and our  ability right then we can be very very  dangerous yes more than anybody and I'm  saying well ya know in bloodsport  although you can also punch someone in  the dick yeah  [Applause]